- [Narrator] Elephantiasis
is a disease spread
through mosquitoes.
Worldwide, over 120 million
people are infected,
and the largest number
of those are in India.
Its symptoms are unmissable.
The most extreme being
swelling in the extremities
that can leave people disfigured for life.
Most people assume that
elephantiasis is untreatable,
but in fact, the opposite is true.
And in India, the race is
on to eradicate it forever.
Rather than cities, the
largest rates of infection
are in villages,
but there are people on the front lines,
like Sheila and Pratima,
who both work for the Ministry of Health,
and who go by foot-village
to village-to help.
Their days start extremely early
as they head out to meet and treat people
across northern India.
(speaking Hindi)
Mosquitoes carry the disease,
so all it takes is one bite
and a person can become infected.
However, the disease has a period
where it's 100 percent treatable,
and the key is getting the medication
that cures it to people early.
But it's an uphill battle,
and for many it's already too late.
(speaking Hindi)
But, change is happening.
And rates of infection
across India are decreasing.
(speaking Hindi)